[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so do I start with the joke about being
a dad or the joke about how I'm addicted
to string G look at it this way
Christian McCaffrey that's like your dad
joke it goes with everything you're
never gonna worry about it's always
gonna be a hit
string cheese is your Tyrell Williams
its matchup specific its venue specific
if you will please okay what are you
thinking the relationship that's gonna
be a big he's right the relationship bit
it is due for a breakout performance
okay so we're going with being a dad
right relationships string cheese and
animal to that dump the animal tax
animal jokes peak like two three years
ago it's not gonna go over will what I'm
chance right
Ted's right that's leave that one in the
past like like I leave Kyle Rudolph in
the past I never ranked them high ever
anymore okay so what should we close
with you should it's time
Wow from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
hey it's time for your fantasy fire
drill we set John kapralos fantasy jokes
and thanks to the Ochocinco for joining
us on the show you never know who may
pop up but I will pop up right here
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific every single
Sunday on all the bleacher report
platforms in one week I'll say that
correctly it might be week 15 but I'll
get it right and we're taking your
questions throughout the show I'll jump
in the app as soon as we're done if
you're in Las Vegas come out to the
sports book cuz maybe you'll get your
question answered right here we have
inactives we have injuries we're gonna
get to those in a second we'll give you
an update from across the pond yeah
there's a game going on right now sorry
if you're playing against Christian
McCaffrey or if you're dealing with
Jameis Winston now on top of all of that
will do the sleepers will even take a
look at the fantasy marketplace who's up
and who's down after five weeks but as
we start every single show we head over
to that giant video board and the names
say the guys that are injured and we
talk about them it's time for inter out
we do so right now for week number six
our early games will update the sport as
we get the official word on all of these
inactives Mark Andrews seems to be a
staple of this every week shoulder
injury on top of everything else he is
expected to play Marquis Brown Hollywood
Brown will not play today it sounded
like he wasn't gonna be out there anyway
really that past the game was Mark
Andrews and I don't care about anybody
else Alvin Kamara expected to plant it
at the ankle issue popped up late look I
know you're probably a little worried
about it don't be it's not that big of a
deal
he plays today you always play Alvin
Kamara moving on here Tyree kill
welcome back Tyree kill clear from miss
clavicle injury is going to play today
he is Justin southside my top 10 but
look you're playing Tyree kill right
back to the wide receiver one
conversation and Sammy Watkins we know
you know what banged up out anyway you
could probably wave goodbye to Sammy
Watkins I don't think he's gonna mean
very much going forward as long as
Tyreke Hill is out there now late games
we do know some things already a
Christian Kirk is very much up in the
air I don't think he's going to play I
would say this if you expected to play
him look
for another option david johnson
expected to play through his back injury
we're gonna talk about chase met Edmonds
a little bit later on he gets a slight
downgrade although I think he'll be
involved sleeper we're gonna talk about
him oh there you go
Todd girl we know is out nice to kind of
know that unfortunately he's out but
it's nice to know that now so you can
make the proper adjustments Malcolm
Brown right into my 1920-21 range so an
okay RB to not a lot of interest in
Darrell Henderson they haven't really
had him back to this year anyway George
Kendall is expected to play through his
injury
popped up late in the week you always
played George Kittel hopefully and get
through the game Jalen Samuels we know
is out is gonna be out for quite some
time I don't care about Benny Snell we
don't have Mason Rudolph this week the
Steelers let's be honest they stink so
don't worry about getting somebody else
there hunter Henry is expected to return
to action this week and you can play him
as a tight end one not a top-five guy
where you may have drafted them but
we'll see if he can work his way back in
Davante Adams is out with the tow and I
am really hoping that this thing doesn't
nag and lag and stick around for very
long but you never know what these
injuries and TJ Hawkinson is expected to
return from his concussion against the
Packers so there you go
that's where we stand as of right now
with the ends with the outs with the
injuries we'll update you if we have any
more but I think we're up to date on
everything there from our early game
connection so now it's time to get to
the first round of questions and let's
do so right now Phillip Lindsey or Joe
Mixon tight one there for Michael I like
mixing if you're sitting one of those
guys you got a pretty darn good team
keeping up here next question admins
Malcolm Brown or mix it in half point
PPR this week you're gonna play mixes
are simple as that I know Malcolm Brown
will start but I'll go a mix it in that
matchup to replace Evan Engram Graham
Walker obviously Howard playing now or
Witten will go with Jimmy Graham against
the Detroit Lions especially with the
injury to Adams would you play chase
Evans over some with a bad matchup like
Al Sean Jeffery perhaps no I would not
al son I would play and I know the match
against Minnesota is not great we'll get
to taste that Vince I'll tell you right
now I think he's a flex option if camara
sits would you pick up a start Murray
absolutely but I don't think that will
be the case if camara
today plays to his injury and he should
Malka browner Tevin Coleman speak I have
gotten this book this seems to be like
me question of the week
I'll tell you to play Malcolm Brown over
seven Coleman as much as I like them
the Niners have like 47,000 running
backs to the board we go for a viewer
question amen
does Garrett I just want to see what you
thought since the Chiefs and Texans are
playing one another is it safer to just
start deshaun Watson against the Chiefs
or Pat mahomes against the Texans thanks
me that is a very enviable position to
be in
mahomes are Watson my number one my
number three quarterback I will tell you
this trade one of those quarterbacks
there's no reason to have both of those
guys someone will give you a king's
ransom for deshaun Watson or mahoma for
that matter when as always mahomes is
qb1 until it gives us a reason not to be
anytime you have two quarterbacks like
that
well you just trade one of them Hutton
we hear music I believe this is our
first update from across the pond
between the Panthers and the Buccaneers
very exciting to seven and McCaffrey has
scored two touchdowns one rushing one
receiving can you believe it how many
touchdowns does Jameis Winston have well
the other stuff was good that was really
up that's what's going on and I believe
Curtis annual may have just scored a
touchdown as we were watching I'm
getting the nods from the crowd that yes
he did so that might help you as well so
the Panthers keep turning it up Jameis
Winston Winston and Britain didn't work
out for some reason I can't believe it
now it's time for your fantasy Stock
Exchange there's good there's bad coming
out of the five weeks so who's on the
way up and staying up it's on the way
down and
well maybe you adjust your expectations
for them going forward let's take a look
at our first name who is on the way up
who's been on the way up since the start
of the season the man in Jacksonville
who's emerged DJ shark yeah I'm not
gonna sing this song about the Sharks
cuz it'll get stuck in your head for the
rest of the day but he scores a
touchdown like every week now and if
you're not playing him as a wide
receiver too
you have not adapted you have not
adjusted he is connected with the man
who game in the blue suit last week
Gardner Minshew he is his guy you know
there FDD Westbrook and Lee and they got
but this guy has emerged and this is a
player you play as a wide receiver too
every week going forward without
question when you connect with a
quarterback and develop that rapport
it's something you latch on to you could
do so with DJ now to the other side
we're talking that guy up and we have
what happened there was so much
excitement in Cleveland people were like
this is our year we're done Sports
Illustrated and Baker Mayfield look
shook he looks like one of the worst
starting quarterbacks in the NFL it's
crushing the value of Odell Beckham I'm
gonna put a little Assange on Dorsey I'm
gonna put a lot of it on John Dorsey
because their old line is atrocious and
it has messed this guy up and he's got
to get out of the hole that has been dug
for him with this bad outline and is
crushing the value of Beckham who'd you
drafted as a wide receiver one you have
to lower expectations there Baker
Mayfield until further notice is not a
starting caliber fantasy quarterback and
it pains me to say that but we have to
admit to what's going on it's not good
right now in Cleveland now some down
back to up we go
balinese up this week no doubt about it
Austin Hooper he might be a top three
tight end this week he's got the
Cardinals that's always good but talking
about a player had a 70 reception season
last year and is on his way to way more
than that maybe the most consistent
falcon right now is Austin Cooper
probably not a good thing because the
Falcons record is not very good but you
know you've been dealing with Calvin
Ridley we'll get to Mohamed Sanu julio
sometimes take all four quarters to come
through for you
this guy's getting it done if you have
Austin Hooper you have an advantage at
the tight end position especially today
against the Cardinals okay back to the
down we go who stopped
is down it's Duke Johnson I kind the
warranty about this one they gave up a
third-round pick to get him everybody
assumes all right it's time for Duke
Johnson to get the big workload that he
never got in Cleveland and it's not
happening Duke Johnson didn't have a 100
carry season other than his first year
it was like 102 that's not a big number
he is yet to have a double-digit carry
game this year now I'm not saying that's
right but we know that he's not getting
enough touches they have Carlos side
there will that change today
it could against the Chiefs that if you
took Duke Johnson on your team to be a
top 25 running back he is not that guy
right now adjust expectations it's not
happening for Duke Johnson who it is
happening for in Arizona is a man that
even I may have overlooked it maybe you
took is your fifth wide receiver who
might be top 15 this week especially if
Christian Kirk can't play because he's
got the Falcons Larry Fitzgerald the
future hall-of-famer he's running a ton
of routes he's getting a bunch of
targets they throw a bunch when in doubt
get players from teams with bad defenses
because they have to throw more it's
happening with Larry Fitzgerald and you
just keep rolling with Larry Fitzgerald
because volume rules all rules all and
also helps that he's pretty darn good as
well
all right one more we took the positive
there now we go back to the negative the
demo Jay did he catch one yet did he
score a touchdown I'm watching the game
I think he's got like one or two catches
today
the only time he apparently catches is
when he's got a Tampa Bay Rays hat on as
we saw the other night look at this
amazing catch by OJ Howard
is he like hot hands and little Giants
do you have to throw them the toilet
paper so we have Winston throwing on
baseballs instead because apparently
he's not going to be catching footballs
with a lot of volume any time soon great
catch there unfortunately his best catch
of the season came in the Hat of the
Rays and not the helmet of the
Buccaneers there's your fantasy Stock
Exchange adjust accordingly we'll take a
look at that again in a few weeks but
now back to your questions we know for
week six how can I help you let's find
out right now D Johnson fits or gallop I
just talked up [ __ ] you gotta play them
this week as much as I like Michael
Gallup good spot to be in for deep
Johnson fits your guy Metcalf for Sinuhe
we're gonna talk about some new very
shortly so I'll tell you right now that
you can play hit next one up here Ravens
or the Cowboys the love the Cowboys
defense this week featured for me in my
big board so get them in your lineup
this week Meg Griffin rivers or Goff God
Ferguson diner scares me a little bit
but I will play them this week lower in
QB 1
I think Rivers is more of a top 15 type
of guy all right keeping up going here
Maclaurin or charkh you can't sit chart
I think he's a rock solid as it gets
right now so continue to play him this
week against the Saints Tyler bordure
Adam feeling fair question there I like
feeling this week against that Eagles
secondary something that you can feel
pretty good about is going against that
secondary more on that a little bit but
to the board we go again for a be our
personality question okay I have okay I
have a fantasy question for this week I
need to figure out what I'm gonna do
with my Flex position I'm really
choosing between Larry Fitzgerald or
Courtland son Courtland son has had some
really big games I know so I can see why
I should put him in there but then for
Larry Fitzgerald Christian Kirk is out
so should I just think they're gonna
rely on Fitzgerald to be like their star
receiver that game I don't know what do
you think about the matchup who do I
play
do I go Fitzgerald with the vet or do I
lean on Sutton let me know Taylor Oaks
just beat out Adam left go for the
longest question asked by a bleacher
report personality Congrats to her and
congrats to playing Larry Fitzgerald
this week I talked him up a bunch look
if I can avoid Joe Flacco nothing
personal I'm gonna avoid Joe Flacco
something's been very up and down you
got Sanders there as well the Broncos
are terrible I'm gonna play Larry
Fitzgerald lot coming his way once again
today thanks the Taylor rooks for the
question and now it's time for my deep
sleepers
[Music]
now last week teddy bridgewater I gave
you as a deep sleeper and people said
what are you doing he has done anything
all year will you play the matchups
you played the matchups against teddy
bridgewater last week you got your four
touchdowns who do we have you for this
week we'll start with the quarterback
who I told you I would keep an open mind
about and I got them in there
min-soo mania is here if you go to
Jacksonville today they're giving you
the mustache and the headband and all
that stuff yeah the hype and all the
stuffs kind of ridiculous but the
production is there he's got the Saints
that's a good matchup for quarterbacks
this season and when in doubt look for
legs he runs there's always bonus there
in running the football he's willing to
do so he's connecting with DJ Turkey's
getting the job done take a look at
Gardner Minshew is my number 13
quarterback for this week certainly
worth a look if you're streaming the
position now we go to a running back
here for our next spot and I said this
earlier it's chase Edmunds I'm not quite
as high on him because David Johnson's
expected to play but if you've had David
Johnson you know this guy's kind of been
a thorn in your side cuz he's been
involved
I still think he'll stay involved Kirk
is banged up he's getting involved as a
runner and a receiver the matchup
against the Falcons is excellent one of
the worst teams and defending
pass-catching running backs he's doing
enough I would say chase Edmunds can be
considered a solid flex option this week
especially in PPR formats now one more
we will give you here and it's a name we
just got a question about it's Mohamed
Sanu
I am guilty of this always rank Coolio
high always rank Calvin Ridley higher
than this guy but if you look at the
numbers this guy's right there with
everybody in Atlanta now when in doubt I
feel like he's a great security blanket
not only for your fantasy team but for
Matt Ryan and we always talk about
playing against that Cardinal secondary
when it comes to the tight ends why did
you get the tight ends working out of
the slot you could take advantage of
Arizona's issues there and do so with
someone like Mohamed Sanu slot receivers
have been a problem for the Cardinals
that's Mohamed Sanu today now more your
questions we go to getting ready for
week six this is I believe the YouTube
exclusive part of the show so we're
looking at for you you
tube digs we're gonna go with Diggs or a
ton I'm gonna go with Diggs I don't know
who that is the other person get your
names right if we're gonna do this year
keep it going
Miko Harmon or DD Westbrook you do have
Tyree kill back this week but I'm still
gonna go with Hardman when in doubt I'll
lean towards the better team Westbrook
has not done much because charkas
rolling Kyle who is the better matchup
to sweep the Chargers or the Ravens I do
lean Ravens there when and doubt I think
they will bounce back I talked up with
Mark Jackson this week in my big board
article keep it up here Moritz should I
start fuller carry on Johnson or breed
as a flex I like carry on Johnson is a
low-end RB one this week I don't think
he should be asked a lot of questions
about that guy he is the most consistent
player for the Lions often should I be
worried about Alvin Kamara points wise
an injury wise look anytime a guy comes
in with an injury you got to be thinking
about it but it's one of the best
running backs in football you play them
and you hope for the best even if he
doesn't make it through the whole game
MBSR Marvin Jones you don't have atoms
out there this week I'll go with MBS
over Marvin Jones now we help you on
YouTube we help you in the app and
people are here live in Vegas watching
this and they got up early this morning
to come watch the show so now we go out
and help them a host of Chiefs fans you
probably don't need a lot of help what's
your name what's your question I'm
Brandon my question is I've got three
running backs non PPR League got to play
two of them
Le'Veon Bell Leonard fournette marking
room oh good spot there for all three
guys you got four net non PPR you like
Ingram Le'Veon Bell
let's sit lay beyond Bell this week
although you might have a trade to make
there if you want to go do some a good
luck to you and the Chiefs this week
cheese fans they're happy and we set
their lineups and now it's back the
piano music here it's time for a matte
moment
hi everybody I'm Matt Kemp do you want
or a ski-doo money oh yeah the respect
of your parents
all this plus Moore's money can be yours
if you ordered my book
we're selling a narrative right that's
what we're doing here it's time to
believe in certain narratives I'll take
you inside my mind you see those
sleepers that pop up every week believe
in the narrative here's what I'm saying
about that the Cardinals are bad against
slot receivers are bad against tight
ends you upgrade players in that spot
the Eagles have a great run defense not
set I'm telling you in a doubt bench
Dalvin cook but they don't have a great
secondary so you fire up digs and
dealing today with confidence the falcon
defense stinks when in doubt play your
guys against them if you upgrade a guy
the Patriots defense is awesome you
downgrade your players there you play
everybody against the Dolphins you'd
really try to stay away from the
Washington Redskins at all purposes some
of these narratives are starting to be
said I'm not saying they're set in stone
but what I'm telling you is there's some
trends that we can now follow four and
five week chunks that's how NFL teams
find their trends that's how they study
that's what you should be doing as well
start to believe in those narratives
because they'll help you boost players
up and find sleepers as well ins and
outs in actives for the early games we
get back to them right now we have all
the information Mark Andrews is going to
be in today so we can tell you that
Marquis Brown is out you just
accordingly it's a bit of a bummer Alvin
Kamara is in hey there we go nothing to
worry about there yeah the injuries
there let's just hope he gets through it
he should be fine against the Jaguars
Tyreke he'll welcome back Tyree kill the
clavicle injury he was cleared from it
he plays today you playing with
confidence and maybe it kind of helps
that you don't have to think about Sammy
Watkins this week because he is out and
probably doesn't have a heck of a lot of
fantasy value going forward as long as
Tyreke Hill stays in the field now late
games we know some things right now
Christian Kirk is very much up in the
air I will tell you this if you don't
have a pivot point and you have to make
a call on Kirk now or in the next hour
and a half just put them in your on your
bench David Johnson is expected to play
now back issues you always worry about
does he does it lock up in pregame
warmups he is expected to play I did
downgrade chase Edmunds to a Flex spot
Todd Gurley we know is out and kind of
helpful that we know that already
Malcolm Brown a decent RB to this week a
George Kittel expected to play there's
worry about him getting through the
whole game who don't you say that about
when it comes to the NFL six weeks into
the season you're playing George Kendall
today Jalen Samuels is out I don't care
about Benny Snell they're down to the
third quarterback Mason Rudolph out look
if you're worried about juju Smith
Schuster you don't care about the third
running back for the Pittsburgh Steelers
so just avoid them a hunter Henry is
expected to return to action today a
low-end tight end one can we just get
this guy to stay on the field and
perform because the talent is there
Davante Adams you already know is out of
the toe allison a little bump MBS a
little bit of a bump but it would be
nice to see the Packers offense operate
at a high level on a consistent basis
and TJ Hawkinson is expected to be fully
cleared from his concussion and return
this week he can get back into the tight
end one conversation all right we're
towards the end of the show speed around
time here the Bell
[Music]
speed round time we'll get to as many
questions as we can coach what do you
think you've got me confused with me
cousin the Cochise from Chicago I'm the
manager from their main streets of
Westminster okay I got an update for you
27:10 Carolina running all over like
they want Graham's Christmas pudding oh
my goodness they get down they get back
up again you're never gonna keep him
down hit him with it Chumbawamba
that wasn't dicta but here we are it's
time for the speed round get to as many
as we possibly can Stafford or Goff I
know God's got the match against the
Niners but I will play them over
Stafford this week gala day or woods how
do you have that possible question I'm
gonna go with Kenny Gallaudet he has
been playing quite well for the Lions
would you start Harvin or Pringle for
the Chiefs not an official chip guy I'll
go with Hardman although attire to kill
back you're not feeling great about any
other chief receiver David Johnson's
back games are gonna be a lingering
issue I'm 34 my back's been bothering
for like 20 years so yeah I hope it's
not the case
should I stream AP or Drake over Sadie I
don't want to touch that
Redskins Dolphins game with a 45 foot
pole I'm playing Sheila shady McCoy this
week Derrick cook Manson Donald Jimmy
Graham I don't love any of these guys
I'll play Jimmy Graham doll against the
Lions knowing that Adams is out with the
toe injury 49ers against the Rams
Redskins against the Dolphins I think
that's a defensive game between the
Redskins of the Dolphins so I'll touch
it with the Redskins defense sorry
Kindle or Andrews we'll go with George
kettle there I've never been seing that
guy keeping up here Watson or Wilson at
quarterback
I have Watson at 3:00 we will play him
but Trent much like we got a question
earlier you have a quarterback trade to
make should I dump Goff or Jimmy G from
into
maybe Jimmy G but I think ninja is gonna
be a streamer guy kinda like how the
Niners are looking right now need to
flex for PPR Damian Williams Hollywood
round out or Jordan Howard I'll tell you
to play Damian Williams I think he finds
his way back into the mix this week and
that's it but if I didn't get to your
question on YouTube or in the app I'm
jumping in the app for the next 30
minutes we'll get you covered there as
we do every single week you join us
right here I got you covered in the week
big board on Wednesdays sleepers on
Friday the app mailbag on Friday but
most importantly right here at the
sports book in Las Vegas 11:30 Eastern
8:30 Pacific tell everybody you know
tell the people across the pond we're
sorry for all that stuff today
we're gonna be back over here with you
every single Sunday for your fantasy
fire drill I'm at camp good luck in week
six
you